[Music]  [Music]  mom Who am I you are a gift  we believe that you came here for a  reason  has been difficult for you okay you feel  different from other kids  Gatling commando he's a creep help me  Mom  I don't want them in handcuffs I know  what I'm going do you even know who is  real mothers  I miss your mother let's go  maybe there is something wrong with  brandy  ever turn against ourselves she's not  some hey who's messing with me  [Applause]  [Music]  something wrong boy round by chance one  of the only people in your world thank  those how special I am they were  believed to be no survivors among the  268 passengers on board  [Music]  I know there is good inside you  [Music]  [Applause]  we wanted you good man I do  [Music]